the World Economic Forum is your window
to the world this November global
leaders will discuss linking leadership
with livelihood from the 12 to the 14th
of november in mumbai ask a leader a
question that matters to you at the
india economic summit here's your chance
what do you want to ask the leaders at
the summit post your text or video
questions on the World Economic Forum
facebook page or channel the world
economic forum will put the best
questions to some of the most powerful
and influential people in the world at
Mumbai what do you want to ask the
leaders at the summit go to whch /
facebook or youtube com / Davos and
submit your question to a leader today